philipp hat als juror beim ingeborg
bachmann wettbewerb mitgemacht was ist
dir bachmann preis ein wettlesen in
klagenfurt für mich ist das das schönste
ereignis im jahr ist nicht zu treffen
und es ging hoch her lieber philipp muss
man ganz vorsichtig auszudrücken
ich sehe in diesem text keinerlei zugang
ich sehe keine öffnung ich sehe keine
bereitschaft zum dialog später tinkler
sie haben einen sehr engen blick kollege
tiger wir müssen mit diesen
zwischenrufen aufpassen denn das
funktioniert so technisch gesehen sehr
schwer
lebst du noch die frage ist ob die
anderen noch leben ich glaube alle sind
wohlauf und am leben ich habe eine eine
seite von dir kennengelernt die mir zwar
nicht ganz neu war aber die mich dann
doch irgendwie ein bisschen erschreckt
hat weil ich dich ganz anders kenne ich
bin einfach ein bisschen kapiert liebe
kollegen merkt ihr nicht oder wollt ihr
nicht merken dass es hier total
konventionelles text modell ist was euch
hier präsentiert wird also ich war
schwierig aus ich meine ich hatte da
eine front oft genug vor mia oder gegen
mich wie du wie du das sehen willst von
sechs leuten ich und die anderen und so
zu sein da ja also das war schon oft
genug der fall dass ich dann irgendwie
dachte hallo wieso seid ihr damit
zufrieden wie so stören euch diese
haarsträubenden klischees dagegen habe
ich ja gar nichts ich finde du hast sehr
viele kluge sachen gebracht und vor
allem hast du sehr viele anregende
diskussionen aufgebracht also die
diskussion was bedeutet
autobiografisches schreiben wie viel
unterhaltung sollte sein in der
literatur wie ist das verhältnis
zwischen form und inhalt das sind alles
wahnsinnig tolle sachen gewesen du warst
einfach unanständig mein lieber weil ich
immer dachte wenn ich dich eingeschaltet
habe philipp ich würde dir so gern gegen
schienbein treten oder durch schütteln
oder die ein buch auf den kopf werfen
ich gucke immer dazwischen das ist meine
art ich finde du hast die sache wirklich
gecrasht im positiven und dem negativen
ja da mit dieser auffassung stehst du
nicht allein also ging er nicht nur sehr
hoch her zwischen euch in der jury
sondern es war ja auch ganz viel auf
twitter ich glaube du bist die
meistdiskutierte person
twitter wie zb hier ich finde ja dass
durch unser ganzes verhältnis auf den
prüfstand gehört den schuldigen hier
nicht einer meinung zu sein weil du
findest das ist ein qualitätsmerkmal
aber wir sind ja oft nicht einer meinung
wenn sonst ersticken und das finde ich
auch wichtig und richtig ich habe mich
manchmal gefragt ob vielleicht jan
böhmermann sich eingesetzt hat einfach
alles getan um immer wieder das
gleichgewicht zu
das hast du rennst war irgendwie so eine
schöne übereinkunft die mich dann
gestört hat es stört mich wenn dann alle
mehr oder weniger das gleiche sagen das
ist mir wirklich ein anliegen nicola
dass man eine bestimmte idee davon
vermitteln kann was ist ein warum sollte
es eigentlich gehen bei literatur warum
lesen wir was ist wichtig an der tour
das ist ja auch mein anliegen ich weiß
aber mein anliegen ist auch der anderen
seite auch aber zu sagen so geht es
nicht
was hat margaret thatcher im hintergrund
zu suchen
ich hatte total lustig wie ein einfaches
bild in einem schlichten zu hause
plötzlich gegenstand einer großen
debatte wird man kann viele kritisieren
ich als homo kann ganz viel an ihr
kritisieren und es ist auch nicht so
dass ich das nicht tun würde das war
eine reine provokation sehe sie als
verkörperung einer einer bestimmten
haltung
ich finde einfach dass margaret thatcher
auch deswegen interessant ist weil sie
so eine wahnsinnig kontroverse figur ist
das heißt es gibt leute auf die man sich
sehr viel schneller einigen kann als auf
margaret thatcher ich bin die margaret
thatcher des literaturbetriebs das ist
ja auch eine plage geworden
also ich möchte schon noch darauf
hinweisen dass ich auch sachen gut fand
ich liebe seit heute helga schubert frau
schubert wenn sie mich hören ich liebe
sie wie ist denn jetzt deine zeigt eine
ganz persönliche bilanz gehörst du dahin
ich glaube
ich gehöre vielleicht da hin weil ich
nicht da hingehöre